from our investigators tonight they're
learning more about the Las Vegas lawyer
accused in a very elaborate Ponzi scheme
50-year-old Matthew Beasley was arrested
by FBI agents at his home in March of
last year Beasley writing a letter to
the FBI that was recently released
stating quote first and foremost let me
say that I am the only one responsible
for this entire mess nobody knew any
details because I kept everything to
myself intentionally everything went
nuts I was really just borrowing money
to pay my gambling debts instead it
turned into this I have no excuse
Beasley faces felony money laundering
and wire fraud charges